This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the 15 years we've been making this show, a lot of podcasts have reached out saying that we in some way inspired their approach to storytelling. But to me, the podcast that consistently embodies the spirit of 99PI while still infusing their episodes with a thoughtfulness and care that makes everything completely their own is 20,000 Hertz. Imagine 99% invisible, but every beautiful. crafted story is about sound. Every once in a while I hear an episode of 20,000 Hertz, and it's such a definitive statement on a subject that I think I just have to share this. And that's what I have for you today. This is the story of the Roland TR808 drum machine. Before they were all over popular
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在我们制作这个节目的15年里，许多播客联系过我们，说我们在某种程度上启发了他们的叙事方法。但对我而言，有一档播客始终体现着99PI的精神，同时又注入了一种周到与关怀，使每一集都完全独具特色，它就是《20000赫兹》。想象一下《99%隐形》，但每一个精雕细琢的故事都是关于声音的。每隔一段时间，我听到一集《20000赫兹》，它对某个主题的阐述是如此权威，以至于我觉得必须把它分享给大家。这就是我今天要带给您的内容。这就是罗兰TR-808鼓机的故事。在它们风靡流行
music, drum machines had a humble origin. They were originally built into home organs, with chintzy sounds that plunked along to preset rhythms like the cha-cha and the fox trot and the waltz. But The earth-shaking 808 changed everything, and its seismic waves spread out far beyond music that had an electronic backing beat. It introduced an addictive low-end rumble, and pop music was never the same. You're listening to 20,000 Hertz. I'm Dallas Taylor. Whenever I listen to vintage music, one of the first things that I notice is a last thing. of bass. For example, in 1912, the top song in America was The Haunting Melody by Al Jolson.
音乐之前，鼓机有着卑微的起源。它们最初内置于家用风琴中，发出俗气的声音，伴随着恰恰舞、狐步舞和华尔兹等预设节奏叮咚作响。但震撼人心的808改变了一切，它的地震波远远扩散到了拥有电子伴奏节拍的音乐之外。它引入了一种令人上瘾的低音隆隆声，流行音乐从此再也不一样了。您正在收听的是《20000赫兹》。我是达拉斯·泰勒。每当我听老音乐时，我注意到的第一件事就是缺乏低音。例如，在1912年，美国排名第一的歌曲是阿尔·乔尔森的《挥之不去的旋律》。
Tell me, have you ever heard, yes, melody? Since this was recorded with a full orchestra, there's almost certainly a double bass in there, but you'd never know it from the record. Twenty years later, things were not much better. Here's a Louis Armstrong track from the early 30s. In this one, the double bass is just barely audible. In the 1950s, the bass started becoming a bit more noticeable. In Bill Haley's Rock Around the Clock, you can definitely hear what the bassist is playing, though it's still pretty quiet. A decade later, bass guitars were much more common, but the recordings were still pretty
告诉我，你可曾听过，是的，旋律？由于这是用完整乐队录制的，里面几乎肯定有一把低音提琴，但你从唱片里绝对听不出来。二十年后的情况也没有好多少。这是30年代初的一首路易斯·阿姆斯特朗的曲子。在这首歌中，低音提琴几乎微不可闻。到了20世纪50年代，低音开始变得更引人注意了一点。在比尔·海利的《昼夜摇滚》中，你绝对能听到贝斯手在弹什么，尽管声音还是很小。十年后，低音吉他（贝斯）普及多了，但录音听起来仍然相当
thin. In this Rolling Stones track, the bass guitar and kick drum just aren't very present. Now, it's not that people back then didn't care about bass. The microphones they had just weren't very good at capturing those frequencies. And even if they could, the speakers and headphones that people had just couldn't reproduce those low-pitched sounds. But in the 60s and 70s, a few different companies released microphones that were much more sensitive to low frequencies. At the same time, people started investing in stereo systems that could blow those old 50s radios out of the water. The result was an explosion of bass-heavy music, from rock classics like Dazed and Confused, To disco hits like La Freak
单薄。在这首滚石乐队的曲子中，贝斯和底鼓的存在感实在不强。现在，并不是说当时的人们不在乎低音。他们拥有的麦克风只是不太擅长捕捉这些频率。即使他们能捕捉到，人们拥有的扬声器和耳机也根本无法重现那些低音。但在60年代和70年代，一些不同的公司发布了对低音频率敏感得多的麦克风。与此同时，人们开始投资那些能把50年代老收音机秒得渣都不剩的立体声音响系统。其结果就是低音重磅音乐的大爆发，从诸如《眩晕与迷糊》这样的摇滚经典，到迪斯科热曲如《La Freak》
All that pressure Got you down Has to hit spinning all around But as bassy as that is, it's nowhere near the booming, sub-rattling tones we hear today. To vacation They ain't never had a dedication To unlock a sound like that, musicians would need something truly revolutionary.
所有的压力压得你喘不过气不得不让唱片四处旋转然而，尽管低音这么重，它也远不及我们今天听到那种轰鸣、震动低音的音色。去度假他们从来没有过奉献精神为了解锁这样的声音，音乐家们需要真正具有革命性的东西。
It was a little device that came out in the early 80s And went on to transform the sound of popular music, The 808 Drum Machine. The 808 is everywhere. You may or may not know it by name, but you've definitely heard it before. I love to take with somebody Brass monkey
那是一个小设备，在80年代初问世，并进而改变了流行音乐的声音，它就是808鼓机。808无处不在。你可能知道也可能不知道它的名字，但你绝对听过它。我喜欢和别人一起拿... 铜猴（Brass Monkey）
That funky monkey I laugh because I laugh because if I listen to the radio for an hour there's not one record that you hear that's not an 808. That's DJ Jazzy Jeff. He's a world-renowned DJ, producer, and hip-hop icon. Famously, he was Will Smith's partner back in his fresh prince days.
那个时髦的猴子我笑是因为，我笑是因为如果我在收音机听一个小时，找不到一张没用808的唱片。那是DJ Jazzy Jeff。他是世界著名的DJ、制作人和嘻哈偶像。众所周知，他在当年“新鲜王子”的年代是威尔·史密斯的搭档。
Commanding the cut, he's always on track. He's DJ Jazzy Jeff and he's a cut man, he acts up for your personal safety, you should be told that my DJ Jazzy Jeff is. We were seeking out what we heard on the early hip-hop records and the machines that they used. there was nothing that was more distinctive and more sought after than the 808. The Roland TR808 is a drum machine. That's Paul McCabe from Roland, the company that created the 808.
掌控切歌，他总是在状态。他是DJ Jazzy Jeff，他是个剪辑高手，他为了你的人身安全而表现得很疯狂，你应该被告知我的DJ Jazzy Jeff是。我们在寻找早期嘻哈唱片中听到的声音以及他们使用的机器。没有什么比808更具辨识度、更让人梦寐以求了。罗兰TR-808是一台鼓机。那是来自罗兰公司的保罗·麦凯布，该公司创造了808。
When they first released it back in the early 80s, drum machines weren't exactly sought after. For 20 or 30 years, they had mostly been used in the home. We have to remember in the 70s, the 60s, the 50s. Music being played in the home was still a very popular thing, and television hadn't taken over the living room quite yet, so families would often gather around and they would play music. People would play music as a pastime. A high percentage of the population was playing music. And though families were hanging out in the living room playing music, they typically
当他们在80年代初首次发布它时，鼓机并不怎么抢手。在20或30年的时间里，它们主要被用于家庭。我们必须记住，在70年代、60年代、50年代。在家里播放音乐仍然是一件非常受欢迎的事情，电视还没有完全占领客厅，所以家人经常聚在一起播放音乐。人们把播放音乐作为一种消遣。很大一部分人口都在演奏音乐。尽管家人聚在客厅里播放音乐，但他们通常
didn't have a drum kit laying around. They might have a guitar, maybe a piano, or a an organ. As you can imagine, people wanted a rhythmic instrument that wasn't as big or loud as a live drum kit. If you see photos of some of the earliest drum machines, in fact, you'll even see drum machines that are designed to sit on top of an organ where the music rust would normally be. So particularly the earliest drum machines, we're really working to try and recreate the sound of a small acoustic drum kit, and so there would be a kick drum and a snare drum and symbols and tom-toms. For years, drum machines were used casually, and professional musicians mostly ignored
家里并没有一套架子鼓。他们可能会有一把吉他，也许是一架钢琴，或者一台风琴。正如你所想象的，人们想要一种节奏乐器，它不像现场架子鼓那么大或那么吵。事实上，如果你看到一些最早的鼓机的照片，你甚至会看到那些设计成放在风琴顶部的鼓机，通常是放在乐谱架原本所在的位置。因此，尤其是最早的鼓机，它们真的在努力尝试重现小型原声架子鼓的声音，所以会有一个底鼓、一个军鼓、镲片和通鼓。多年来，鼓机都被随意地使用，而专业音乐人大多忽略了
them. But in time, musicians did start to find uses for drum machines. By the early 70s, many songwriters would program a drumbeat and then write to it. Now, most of the time, this drum machine would get replaced by a live drummer. But not always. One of the first recordings to include a drum machine was Family Affair by Sly and the Family Stone. It's the family affair. It's the family affair. Around the same time, early versions of electronic music were starting to go mainstream.
它们。但假以时日，音乐家们确实开始发现鼓机的用途。到70年代初，许多词曲作者会编程一个鼓点，然后对着它进行创作。现在，大多数时候，这个鼓机会被现场鼓手所取代。但并不总是这样。最早包含鼓机的录音之一是斯莱和斯通家族乐队的《家庭事务》。这是家庭事务。这是家庭事务。大约在同一时期，早期版本的电子音乐开始走向主流。
This is the robots by Craftwork. Craftwork is a four-piece band out of Dusseldorf, Germany. they would be one of the founding fathers of techno. For craftwork, drum machines were a perfect complement to their precise synthesized bass lines. By the late 70s, drum machines were finally gaining traction. They started to become used more in live performance in a situation where either an acoustic drummer wasn't available
这是来自发电站乐队的《机器人》。发电站乐队是来自德国杜塞尔多夫的四人乐队。他们将成为电子乐（Techno）的开山鼻祖之一。对于发电站乐队来说，鼓机是他们精确的合成贝斯线完美补充。到70年代末，鼓机终于获得了动力。它们开始更多地用于现场表演中，在那种情况下，要么没有原声鼓手
or to enhance a rhythm section, and then they started to appear in recordings. At the time, one of the most popular drum machines was the Roland CR-78, which was a predecessor to the 808. Here it is in Blondie's Heart of Glass. And here's the CR-78 in Phil Collins's In the Air Tonight. These songs inspired. required early demand for a stage-ready drum machine, so Roland got to work on a new model.
或者为了增强节奏部，然后它们开始出现在录音中。当时，最受欢迎的鼓机之一是罗兰CR-78，它是808的前身。这是它在金发女郎乐队的《玻璃之心》中的表现。这是CR-78在菲尔·柯林斯的《今夜空气中》中的表现。这些歌曲激发了
They wanted to build a machine that was portable, flexible, and durable. 1-1c's a TR808. It almost looks military. In its design, it's kind of a drab all of color. And there's a reason why TR8 awaits are still being used today, because you could drive a truck over them, and probably many of them would still work. That was kind of what was in our mind at the time. Where it went to, needless to say, is someplace quite different. Over the centuries, there have been a few instruments that changed music forever. The piano revolutionized classical music. Electric guitars defined rock and roll.
对舞台就绪型鼓机的早期需求，于是罗兰开始着手研发新型号。他们想要制造一台便携、灵活且耐用的机器。这就是TR-808。它看起来几乎具有军事风格。在设计上，它是一种单调的军绿色。TR-808至今仍在使用是有原因的，因为你可以开着卡车从它们身上压过去，而且可能其中许多机器仍然能正常工作。这正是我们当时脑海中所想的。不用说，它后来的去向完全是另一回事。几个世纪以来，有几件乐器永远改变了音乐。钢琴革新了古典音乐。电吉他定义了摇滚乐。
In the 808, transformed hip-hop and electronic music. When we think about the sound of the 808, we think of it in terms of its influence on hip-hop and R&B. And, you know, when we think of hip-hop, of course, we start with Africa-Babata and Planet Rock. It's this otherworldly mashup of this kind of East Coast New York sound with craftwork.
而808改变了嘻哈和电子音乐。当我们想到808的声音时，我们会想到它对嘻哈和R&B的影响。而且，你知道的，当我们想到嘻哈时，我们当然要从非洲班巴塔（Afrika Bambaataa）和《星球摇滚》（Planet Rock）开始。这是东海岸纽约之声与发电站乐队的一种异世界的大融合。
Like a lot of musicians at the time, DJ Jazzy Jeff heard Planet Rock and was captivated by the drum sounds. We emulated whatever we heard. So, you know, when Planet Rock came out, it was kind of like, I need that machine. There was no drum machine that had a kick drum that sounded like that, that had a snare that sounded like that, that had a Christmas to the hi-hats like an 808. So it was definitely sought after so that you could kind of make these records.
像当时的许多音乐人一样，DJ Jazzy Jeff听到了《星球摇滚》，并被鼓声深深吸引。我们模仿听到的任何东西。所以，你知道的，当《星球摇滚》问世时，就有点像，我需要那台机器。没有任何一台鼓机的底鼓听起来像那样，没有任何鼓机的军鼓听起来像那样，也没有任何鼓机的踩镲像808那样具有清脆感。所以它绝对是人们梦寐以求的，这样你才能做出这些唱片。
Once these DJs got their hands on the 808, they started expanding on its possibilities. Listen, listen. There was a record funkbox party by Mastodon Committee, and he was a DJ that was very, very good on an 808. Musicians were experimenting. Here's Egyptian lover over on the West Coast. And here's some 808 electrofunk from a group called the SOS band.
一旦这些DJ们拿到808，他们就开始挖掘它的无限可能。听着，听着。有一张唱片是Mastodon Committee的《Funkbox Party》，他是一个非常擅长使用808的DJ。音乐家们正在进行实验。这里是西海岸的埃及情人（Egyptian Lover）。这里还有来自一个叫SOS乐队的808电音放克（Electro-funk）。
Here's Indian musician Cherinzeet sing, using an 808 on his album 10 Raghaz to a disco beat. And here's Marvin Gaye's more minimalist use of the 808. As the 808 took off, it wasn't clear and it could. As the 808 took off, it wasn't clear if this sound had any staying power. It could just be a flash in the pan that would be replaced by the next big thing.
这里是印度音乐家查林齐特·辛格（Charanjit Singh），他在自己的专辑《十首拉格》中将808用于迪斯科节拍。这里是马文·盖伊对808更为极简的使用。随着808的腾飞，这种声音是否具有持久力并不明朗。它可能只是昙花一现，很快就会被下一个大趋势所取代。
There was all these moments that were happening, these musical moments that were very serendipitous in the early 80s, that, you know, if they'd gone left instead of right, if this guy did this on a Tuesday instead of a Wednesday, we probably wouldn't be talking about the 808 in this context today. It was literally that kind of magical.
有所有这些正在发生的时刻，80s初那些非常机缘巧合的音乐时刻，你知道的，如果他们向左而不是向右走，如果这家伙在周二而不是周三做了这件事，我们今天可能就不会在这样的语境下谈论808了。它就是那种具有魔力。
A huge factor in that magic had to do with the 808's bass drum sound and a little knob for controlling it labeled decay. That one tiny knob allowed musicians to push the bass in their music farther than they ever had before, and it created a sound that still dominates to this day. That's coming up, after the break. We're back with more 808 from 20,000 Hertz on 99% Invisible. That's all the numbers I've got for you. When drum machines were first developed, they were meant to replace live drummers,
这种魔力背后一个巨大的因素与808的底鼓声音以及一个用于控制它的、标有“衰减”（decay）的小旋钮有关。正是那一个小小的旋钮，让音乐家们能够把他们音乐中的低音推到前所未有的极致，并创造出一种至今仍占据统治地位的声音。稍后广告回来，我们将为您揭晓。我们带着来自《20000赫兹》的更多808内容回归，节目在《99%隐形》播出。这就是我为您准备的所有数字。当鼓机最初被开发出来时，它们旨在取代现场鼓手，
so the goal was to sound like a real drum kit using artificial sounds. The Roland 808 was designed with the same idea in mind. Even when we got to the TR808, the technology was designed to recreate an acoustic drum kit. The 808 was released in 1980, and at first, it wasn't a big hit. For one thing, it cost $1,200, which is about $4,600 in today's money. And soon after it came out, the 808 got some tough competition. Right about that same time, 1981, the first... drum machine that used recorded sound clips or samples came into being.
所以其目标是使用人工声音来听起来像一个真正的架子鼓。罗兰808的设计也秉持着同样的理念。甚至当我们开发到TR808时，这项技术也是为了重现原声架子鼓而设计的。808于1980年发布，起初它并不是一个大热门。一方面，它的售价为1200美元，相当于今天的约4600美元。就在它问世后不久，808遇到了一些强劲的竞争。大约在那个时候，即1981年，第一台使用录制声音片段或采样的鼓机诞生了。
This new generation of drum machines could play real recorded drum sounds. Once they hit the scene, they made synthesized drum machines like the 808 sound dated. To me, this is very Nintendo and Atari-ish. Here's my computer version of what I think a drum kit is supposed to sound. to sound, and it doesn't sound anything like a drummer or a drum set at all. At the time, an Atari video gamey drum sound just wasn't what people wanted on their records, but after a couple years of mediocre sales, the 808 started showing up in pawn shops for a fraction of the price.
新一代的鼓机可以播放真实录制的鼓声。一旦它们登场，就让像808这样的合成鼓机听起来过时了。对我来说，这非常任天堂和雅达利风格。这是我对架子鼓声音应该是什么样的电脑版本，它听起来一点也不像鼓手或架子鼓。当时，雅达利电子游戏般的鼓声并不是人们想在唱片里听到的，但在经历了几年平庸的销量后，808开始出现在当铺里，而价格只是原价的一小部分。
I ended up getting mine from a pawn shop because you couldn't really walk into a store and see an 808. Musicians started picking them up because it was a piece of equipment they could actually afford. Recording studios often had one on a shelf collecting dust, or somebody's friend might lend them one for a live show. But the jury was still out on whether the 808 was anything more than a cheap machine that couldn't play real drum sounds. The 808 was really facing quite an uphill battle to gain any kind of acceptance. But in a kind of one of these classic,
我的808最终是从当铺买来的，因为你当时无法真正走进一家商店看到一台808。音乐家们开始购买它们，因为这是他们真正买得起的设备。录音室里通常有一台放在架子上积灰，或者某人的朋友可能会借给他们一台用于现场演出。但关于808是否只是一台无法播放真实鼓声的廉价机器，当时还没有定论。808确实面临着相当艰难的阻力，才能获得某种程度的接受。但在某种经典的、
Your Strength is Your Weakness paradoxes where the strength of the drum machines that were based on recordings of actual drum sounds was that at first glance they sounded more natural. On the other hand, certainly with the technology available at that time, you couldn't really adjust the sound that much. We were used to having a drum machine that you were stuck with basically the sound that came out of it. There wasn't too much manipulation that you can do. So to have this machine that you can take the snappiness out of the snare and you can add more boom into the kick.
“你的优势就是你的劣势”的悖论中：基于实际鼓声录音的鼓机的优势在于，乍一看它们听起来更自然。另一方面，当然以当时可用的技术，你无法真正对声音进行太多调整。我们习惯了使用那种你基本上只能接受其发出的声音的鼓机。你无法进行太多的调整。所以有了这台机器，你可以去掉军鼓的清脆感，你可以在底鼓中加入更多的轰鸣感。
This one machine could sound a hundred different ways. The 808 may have sounded artificial, but those video gamey tones were highly adjustable, and that ended up being the key to its success. And so with that in mind, you look and you've got these 11 sounds. Here's the kick. Snare, closed hi-hat, open-high-hat, crash symbol, Tom's
这台机器可以发出一百种不同的声音。808听起来可能很人工，但那些电子游戏般的音色是高度可调节的，这最终成为了它成功的关键。因此，带着这一点，你看看，你拥有这11种声音。这里是底鼓。军鼓，闭合踩镲，开放踩镲，镲片，通鼓
hand clap rim shot cowbell you always got to have more cowbell and finally clave when you start getting into
手拍鼓，边击，牛铃你总是得有更多的牛铃最后是克拉维钟（木鱼声）当你开始接触到
the clav and the cowbell those were two very distinctive sounds that if you put them on anything you knew they came from an 808
克拉维钟和牛铃时，那是两种非常独特的声音，如果你把它们用在任何东西上，你就会知道它们来自808
but there was one sound on 808 that changed music forever, the bass drum, also known as the kick. There was a point in time that I felt like people were afraid of kick drums. You couldn't have the kick drum too loud. You couldn't have it too boomy. Here's Scorpio by Grandmaster Flash and The Furious Five. You can hear that the kick drum is relatively low in the mix. Someone had the heart.
但808有一种声音永远改变了音乐，那就是低音鼓，也被称为底鼓。曾有一段时间，我觉得人们对底鼓感到害怕。你不能把底鼓开得太大声。你不能让它太轰鸣。这里是Grandmaster Flash and The Furious Five的《Scorpio》。你能听到底鼓在混音中相对较低。有人有这个勇气
to put an 808 kick drum that it was round and it was boomy and it felt really good. Here's Planet Patrol with a rounder, louder kick drum. Then somebody on a record opened up the decay. And when that kick drum rang out, it was nothing like you've ever heard. Here's DJ Jazzy Jeff himself opening up that decay and letting the kick drum drive the song. Have you ever in your life experience the day where nothing at all seemed to go your way? No matter how hard you try to get out of the rut, you just could not break the string of that lock a day where Murphy ball takes...
去放一个圆润且轰鸣、感觉非常棒的808底鼓。这里是Planet Patrol带来的更圆润、更响亮的底鼓。接着，唱片里的某个人打开了衰减（decay）。当那个底鼓回响起来时，那是你从未听过声音。这里是DJ Jazzy Jeff本人打开了那个衰减，让底鼓驱动着整首歌。你这一生中可曾经历过这样一天：似乎诸事不顺？无论你多么努力想摆脱困境，你就是无法打破霉运的一天，墨菲定律发生了……
Soon enough, the sound of the 808 bass drum became synonymous with hip-hop. The idea of young people driving down the street with big, boomy subwifers was largely because of that tone. Here's LaTrem, a Miami-Base hip-hop duo singing about Boomy Car Stereo's in 1988. Notice the signature sustained 808 bass drum sound. Because when you're in the street, you can't go far without hearing the boom pouring out your car. 20 years later, Felix to Housecat released the song Kick Drum, which pushes that decay to its absolute limit. Today, artists often shift the pitch of these 808 kick sounds to create full-on bass lines. Over the last couple decades, this technique has been used in hit song after hit song.
很快，808底鼓的声音就成了嘻哈音乐的代名词。年轻人开着车在街上转悠，车里装着巨大的、轰鸣的低音炮，很大程度上就是因为那种音色。这里是LaTrem，一个来自迈阿密的嘻哈二人组，在1988年歌唱着轰鸣的汽车音响。注意那标志性的持续808底鼓声音。因为当你在街上时，你走不了多远就会听到轰鸣声从你的车里倾泻而出。20年后，Felix to Housecat发行了歌曲《Kick Drum》，将这种衰减推到了极致。今天，艺术家们经常改变这些808底鼓声音的音高来创作完整的低音线。在过去的几十年里，这种技术在热门歌曲中被一遍又一遍地使用。
It's in Hotline Bling by Drake. It's in DNA by Kendrick Lamar. It's in Up by Cardi B. By now, we've heard these booming bass tones in hundreds, if not thousands of tracks. But back in the early 80s, a sound like that was unheard of. You're not supposed to have your bass drum driving that much. And it's kind of like, why not? Everybody's riding around in their car playing this music and it's vibrating their car and they enjoy that.
德雷克的《Hotline Bling》里有它。肯德里克·拉马尔的《DNA》里有它。Cardi B的《Up》里有它。到目前为止，我们在成百上千首歌曲中都听到过这些轰鸣的低音。但在80年代初，这样的声音是闻所未闻的。你的底鼓本不应该驱动这么大。这就好比，为什么不呢？每个人都开车兜风，放着这种音乐，音乐震动着他们的汽车，他们很享受这一点。
There's no right and wrong in it. I really feel like the 808 kick drum was one of the first things that started shattering the rules of what you should or shouldn't do when it came to recording music. The decay control basically turned the 808's bass drum into a whole new instrument. It was so different that the studios making early hip-hop records didn't even know what to do with it. When we did, he's the DJ, I'm the rapper, was the first record that I used 808s and 808 samples on that I wanted the kick drum to really resonate. And I remember fighting with the engineer because I wanted to push the envelope on how long. loud and how deep I wanted the 808 because I knew there were some hip hop records that you would get in a car and you would play it and the entire car would vibrate.
这其中没有绝对的对与错。我真的觉得808底鼓是打破录制音乐时该做什么或不该做什么的规则的首批事物之一。衰减控制基本上将808的底鼓变成了一个全新的乐器。它是如此独特，以至于制作早期嘻哈唱片的录音室甚至不知道该拿它怎么办。当我们制作《He's the DJ, I'm the Rapper》时，这是我第一次在上面使用808和808采样，我希望底鼓能够真正产生共鸣。我记得我和工程师发生了争执，因为我想突破界限，看我能把808做得多长、多响、多深，因为我知道有些嘻哈唱片你拿到车里去放，整辆车都会震动。
And I was like, I want that. But since that was so unusual at the time, the engineer refused. I had to fight with the engineer to turn it up and he would turn it down and turn it up. And I had to kind of explain to him, like I understand that there is a technical way that you think you're supposed to do something. I want to push that envelope. I need this to be this loud. I need to be almost at the brink that it's not distorting
我说，我就要那种效果。但由于这在当时太不寻常了，工程师拒绝了。我不得不和工程师争论，让他把音量调大，而他却把它调小又调大。我不得不向他解释，就像我明白你认为你应该以某种技术方式去做某事一样。我想突破那个界限。我需要这个声音这么大。我需要它几乎达到不失真
and it's not overpowering everything, but I need this to be the focal point of the record. Hip-hop is something that the drums have to drive the record. And I got him to allow me to do it to the point that I loved it. And what I never realized was I never told the mastering engineer that I wanted that. And he thought it was a mistake, and he took all of the 808 out of the album. And I don't think I've ever said this in public. I can't listen to He's the DJ. I'm the rapper now.
而且不会压倒一切的边缘，但我需要这是唱片的焦点。嘻哈音乐就是鼓点必须驱动整张唱片。我终于说服了他，达到了我喜爱的程度。而我从未意识到的是，我从未告诉母带工程师我想要那种效果。他以为这是一个错误，他把专辑里所有的808低音都去掉了。我想我从来没有在公开场合说过这个。我现在都无法听《He's the DJ, I'm the Rapper》。
That is the biggest record we've ever done, and I absolutely hate the way that it sounds because they sucked all of the bottom in from the 808 out in Master. Here's a clip from He's the DJ, I'm the rapper, as it is on the record. And here's been written, not to be bitten, but as it seems, some suckers keep forgetting the rules about rapping, but that's all right, because in the next five minutes, I'm gonna have them all up tight, stronger than a dinosaur, better known this. And here's what DJ Jazzy Jeff was probably going for. The 808 arrived at exactly the right time. Through the 1970s, the rise of funk and disco made people hungry for thumping bass-heavy music. Then, in the early 80s, the 808 showed up just as hip-hop was starting to take off. It was the perfect storm.
那是我们做过的最大的一张唱片，我绝对讨厌它的声音，因为他们在母带制作中把808所有的低音都抽干了。这里是《He's the DJ, I'm the Rapper》唱片中的一段原声。这里有写好的词，不是为了被抄袭，但似乎有些笨蛋总是忘记关于说唱的规则，不过没关系，因为在接下来的五分钟里，我要让他们全都紧张起来，比恐龙还强壮，也就是这个。这很可能是DJ Jazzy Jeff当时追求的效果。808在绝对正确的时间出现了。贯穿整个70年代，放克和迪斯科的兴起让人渴望充满重低音的动感音乐。接着，在807年代初，808在嘻哈音乐刚开始腾飞之际闪亮登场。这是完美的风暴。
When the 808 was absorbed into hip-hop culture, the ability to create that boom, and the boom was largely driven by where you tuned the kick and then where you adjusted its decay to, that became the signature. So as hip hop grew, the sound of hip hop grew, the backbone of that sound was the 808. Pretty soon, these boomy bass drums spread into R&B,
当808被吸收进嘻哈文化中时，创造那种轰鸣的能力——而这种轰鸣很大程度上是由你调整底鼓音高以及调整其衰减的位置决定的——这就成了标志。所以随着嘻哈的发展，嘻哈的声音也随之发展，该声音的顶梁柱就是808。很快，这些轰鸣的低音鼓蔓延到了R&B、
electronic music, and beyond. Today, the 808 is just everywhere through pop music. And just by saying pop, that's such a wide term now. It encompasses world music, electronic music, and EDM, and techno and house. And it's not an understatement to say that the 808 is an instrument that is actually defined culture. Just like the electric guitar with rock and roll, the 808 allowed musicians to express new ideas, or at least to express timeless ideas in ways that felt new and exciting.
电子音乐以及更多领域。今天，808在流行音乐中无处不在。仅仅通过说“流行”这个词，它现在已经是一个如此广泛的术语。它涵盖了世界音乐、电子音乐、EDM、电子乐（Techno）和浩室音乐（House）。毫不夸张地说，808是一项真正定义了文化的乐器。就像电吉他与摇滚乐一样，808让音乐家能够表达新的想法，或者至少以一种让人感觉新鲜和兴奋的方式表达永恒的想法。
This is why I love music so much, because there's a thousand different combinations in ways to get to a result. At the end of the day, you realize that someone who had a crappy week at work. Depending on how you present this music, you can change their day. You can introduce two people together that end up spending the rest of their lives together just by playing music in a certain way to bring people together. I've been blessed to have a thumbprint in music and making it or playing it that affects people's moods. That's the coolest job in the world. 20,000 Hertz is produced out of the sound design studios of de facto sound. Find out more at de facto sound.com.
这就是我如此热爱音乐的原因，因为达到一个结果有一千种不同的组合方式。到头来，你意识到某个度过了糟糕的一周工作的人。取决于你如何呈现这段音乐，你可以改变他们的一天。你可以把两个最终会共度余生的人撮合在一起，仅仅通过以某种方式播放音乐把人们聚集在一起。我很幸运能在音乐创作或演奏中留下自己的印记，从而影响人们的情绪。这是世界上最酷的工作。《20000赫兹》是由de facto sound的声音设计工作室制作的。了解更多请访问 defactosound.com。
This episode was written and produced by Phil Corbett and Casey Emmerling With help from Grace East It was sound designed and mixed by Joel Boyder And Justin Hollis Thanks to our guests, DJ Jazzy Jeff and Paul McCabe You can find Jeff's latest work at DJJJJJJef.com And a big thanks to One Plus for partnering with us on this episode
本集由菲尔·科bett（Phil Corbett）和凯西·埃默林（Casey Emmerling）编剧和制作，并得到了格蕾丝·伊斯（Grace East）的帮助。声音设计和混音由乔尔·博伊德（Joel Boyder）和贾斯汀·霍利斯（Justin Hollis）完成。感谢我们的嘉宾DJ Jazzy Jeff和保罗·麦凯布。你可以在 DJJJJJJef.com 上找到杰夫的最新作品。非常感谢 One Plus 对本集节目的赞助支持
To learn more, visit Oneplus.com I'm Dallas Taylor. Thanks for listening. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要了解更多信息，请访问 Oneplus.com。我是达拉斯·泰勒。感谢收听。谢谢。此剧集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。